encore aujourd'hui la publicité
frauduleuse sur les crypto monnaie fait
rage sur facebook certains disent
maintenant qu'il est temps de serrer la
vis au fondeur bien sûr mais aussi à
Facebook
j'aurais jamais cru qu'il y avait des
gens aussi méchants pour aller chercher
les sous des gens
au printemps 2022 Johan Gauthier a le
malheur de cliquer sur une publicité
Facebook vantant les rendements des
crypto monnaie à ce moment-là j'écris
comme dit qu'il y a quelqu'un qui va
communiquer avec moi rapidement elle
reçoit l'appel d'un présumé conseillé
financier il pouvait m'appeler au début
le 3-4 fois par jour tu lui dis moi
j'aimerais ça que mes fins de mois
soient un petit peu plus agréable quand
j'ai parlé avec ce monsieur de sel du
premier
fait que il m'a dit on peut se faire
confiance on va travailler plusieurs
années ensemble puis ça va bien aller tu
vas voir
Johan Gauthier commence par investir
quelques centaines de dollars puis en
vient confier pratiquement toute son
épargne à se conseiller qui prétend être
à Toronto et qu'elle n'a jamais vu leurs
échanges sont toujours au téléphone ou
par écrit quelques mois plus tard elle
réalise qu'elle a été flouée quand il
lui est impossible de récupérer son
argent j'ai perdu au total environ 250
000 dollars
il me reste plus rien ben la seule chose
que j'ai pas touché moi c'était mes
réaff Johan Gauthier n'avait
malheureusement pas vu notre reportage
de l'an dernier sur Fernand Larouche qui
a vécu une histoire semblable à la
sienne l'argent de ma retraite je l'ai
tout perdu alors je peux vous dire là
j'ai pas trop fière de ça c'était tout
près d'un million
firmant la ruche aussi avec tu la
malchance de cliquer sur une publicité
trompeuse du même genre sur Facebook et
je vous avoue que avec tout ce que je
voyais la compagnie les chartes son côté
professionnel j'ai perdu de vue que ça
pouvait être une fraude en fait Fernand
Larousse et Johan Gauthier ont été
victimes du même stratagème à un an
d'intervalle
d'abord le riz par une publicité sur
Facebook ils ont ensuite reçu un appel
d'un faux conseiller à l'emploi d'une
compagnie aux allures légitimes qui leur
a fait miroiter des rendements inespéré
nous retrouvons Fernand la rouge durant
ses vacances en Floride il est en colère
contre Facebook moi je considère que
Facebook est totalement irresponsable
là-dedans j'ai revu les mêmes publicités
couramment depuis un an sur Facebook les
mêmes publicités qui m'ont accroché là
nos collègues descripteurs qui traquent
les fausses informations sur les réseaux
sociaux constate la même chose après
midi on était capable de trouver au
moyen de trentaine de publicités pour
ces fraudes là sur Facebook et c'est
aussi omniprésent sur nos profils que ça
l'était apparaît date il y a un an comme
l'an passé les publicités ont des
allures d'articles de journaux émettent
souvent en vedette le grand patron de
Tesla on utilise le nom et le drapeau
canadien on voit encore la pyramide on
commence à 250 et pour augmenter en
quatre semaines jusqu'à 47 500 dollars
[Musique]
mettant la maison mère de facebook
refuse de nous accorder une entrevue à
la caméra la multinationale indique
qu'elle a toujours fait preuve de
fermeté dans sa lutte contre les
arnaques fraude et abus de tout genre
elle encourage les gens à lui signaler
la présence de publicité frauduleuse
ça fait depuis nos moins une dizaine de
fois depuis un an que je signale ces
publicités là
frauduleuses à Facebook mais j'ai jamais
de réponse puis ça continue de tourner
quand même mais t'apprécie ce qu'il est
impossible d'enrayer complètement la
fraude sur ses plateformes mais qu'elle
y consacre des ressources considérables
et l'ajoute que les publicités
identifiées par l'équipe des décrypteurs
ont été retirés tout comme les comptes
qui sont associés on voit que facebook
en général après deux ou trois jours
retirera ses publicités là parce
qu'elles vont à l'encontre c'est
réglement on a vu d'autres qui sont
restés actives aussi longtemps qu'une
semaine sur la plateforme trois jours
dans le domaine de Duster pouzuleuse ça
peut permettre de ruiner pas mal de
monde
à l'université
d'un groupe de travail fédéral sur la
sécurité en ligne désormais la plupart
des fraudes se déroulent en ligne et on
n'a pas vraiment ajuster les lois on
continue de faire comme si les fraudes
c'était des bonnes vieilles fraudes de
quelqu'un qui sonne à la porte de
quelqu'un pour vous vendre un aspirateur
qui fonctionne pas et moi je suis assez
découragé de voir à quel point les
politiques
des États tardent à s'ajuster aux enjeux
du numérique la classe politique ne
semble pas presser de commenter la chose
nous avons communiqué avec les ministres
responsables Pablo Rodriguez Marco
Mendicino François Bonnardel et ericaire
aucun ne nous a accordé une entrevue
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord pour dire
qu'en raison de son inaction le
gouvernement ne protège pas le public
absolument c'est dangereux pour le
public ça ne protège pas le public ça
met le public à risque les pertes liées
au fraude à l'investissement ont
pratiquement doublé en 2022
comparativement en 2021 la plus courante
est celle décrite dans notre reportage
au moins 70 000 $ par victime donc c'est
quand même assez considérable sachant
que c'est une moyenne donc j'ai des
victimes qui ont perdu beaucoup plus que
la moyenne le phénomène est sous-estimé
puisque seulement 5 à 10% des victimes
font un signalement firmant la ruche et
Johan Gauthier eux ont porté plainte à
la police de Gatineau leur lieu de
résidence au moment des faits mais
espoirs sont faibles parce que là on m'a
dit que l'argent était à l'étranger la
réponse qui nous est donnée c'est
compter pour trouver votre argent là
vous avez c'est trop compliqué le
compliqué en effet l'arnaque est
internationale et les fraudeurs à
l'autre bout du monde les autorités dont
la Sûreté du Québec invite donc les
citoyens à faire preuve de prudence sans
vouloir blâmer aucune victime à toutes
les fois où je lis des déclarations de
victimes et que je regarde ce qui s'est
passé il y avait des drapeaux rouges
plusieurs drapeaux rouge c'est facile de
se tenir informé notamment sur le site
Web du Centre canadien anti fraude de
cette mine informée sur le site de l'AMS
de l'autorité de marché financier puis
il y a pas d'alerte suffisante on laisse
passer les publicités frauduleuses mais
apprenez à pas les regarder amener ou
inviter les victimes à être vigilantes
en fait ça me rappelle moi l'époque où
on disait une personne une femme
agressive
on aurait dû s'habiller de manière moins
entre guillemets provocante
et donc moi je pense que
c'est un fardeau pas mal considérable
qu'on implique aux victimes lorsque on
dit bah ils auraient dû vérifier ils
auraient dû aller voir pourtant le
gouvernement pourrait sévir contre
Facebook c'est d'ailleurs ce que fait
l'Australie depuis
l'approche australienne essentiellement
c'est dire écoutez si la fraude a lieu à
partir d'une information une publicité
qui circulait sur votre réseau vous
allez en aide responsable alors c'est
une façon d'inciter les plateformes à
être beaucoup plus proactive pour
limiter les fraudes il faut absolument
que les gouvernements fassent des
législations au moins pour punir les
Facebook de ce monde qui est Facebook
peut abriter n'importe quel escroc ça
fait aucun sens
si Fernand la rouge dit avoir fait la
paix avec la perte de toutes ces
économies pour Johanne Gauthier la
souffrance est toujours vive quand elle
voit son ancienne maison dans tout
l'argent de la vente lui a été dérobé
j'ai raconté l'histoire à ma maison puis
mes petits-enfants savent aussi puis mes
petits-enfants quand je leur offre
quelque chose il me disent garde des
sous mamie tu en as besoin et toi garde
tes sous on va nous dit non dans leur
petit compte de banque là au fait que ça
c'est dur ça c'est vraiment dur mais je
viens de là aussi tes petits enfants
selon les autorités australiennes
Facebook et consciente de l'existence de
ces publicités frauduleuses qui
d'ailleurs lui rapporte de l'argent mais
n'en fait pas assez pour les arrêter
c'est une cause à suivre d'ailleurs
l'émission décrypteur reviendra sur ce
dossier samedi 11h30 sur RDI et par la
suite surtout point TV